- So honestly, the change
from mechanical engineering,
the broader world view to materials,
like this smaller, literally,
atomic world view--
- The project that I'm working
with my AP physics class,
currently is guided by
a need to know question
for the students of,
"How can we successfully put a lander
on the surface of Mars?"
During the final task, task five,
where students did there
drop and qualification tests,
we had a number of engineers
from Blue Origin and Boeing
present and communicating
with the students,
asking a number of great questions.
- Okay, what do the
other designs look like?
- This and this.
- Interesting.
Yeah, how did this one hold up?
- There's motivation for the students
when the project they have
connects to an actual real world problem
and that they see or hear
actual people that have a
job that uses those skills.
I try to make sure that
they've got that connection.
That they see,
here's a person.
We're gonna hear from them.
They're applying the concepts
that you're learning right now
to tackle these real world problems.
- I basically knew I wanted
to be in the aerospace field
since I was around your
age in high school.
It was basically when I learned that
you can get a job building spaceships.
And I was like, "That's it,
that's what I wanna do."
- Give the students a chance to really see
if the language they were using
and the concepts that they
were trying to explain
actually made sense to somebody
besides me or a peer in the classroom.
- Equation, impulse
equals force times time.
- Right.
- So if we change, either force or time,
the other one's gonna react
if impulse is constant.
- That's very insightful.
That's good.
- It helped that they
were using some of the
same vocabulary we were.
It was kind of a connection of,
this is actually a thing that goes on.
- Things can normalize your motion
that you may have underneath.
Underneath that chute can mellow out some
before impact.
- If you manipulate time,
the force also changes.
And so that's how we've
been changing the force.
- [Johnny Voiceover] There is
a lot of great communication
going on,
both directions.
- Hit and then crack all the eggs.
- And then directly, okay cool.
And it sounds like you've
done a little bit of testing
to see if that works.
- Yeah, we've done a fair amount.
- [Johnny Voiceover] The
students are able to understand
what the engineers were
saying back to them
and the engineers also,
seemed to be quite impressed
by the ability of the students
to explain their choices
in the design of their landers
using appropriate physics language.
- We were really just focused
on the maximum air resistance.
- Yeah, that makes sense.
- That we could get.
- We often struggle with the fact
that we're trying to
teach students knowledge
for jobs that don't exist yet
and that's how quickly
things are changing,
especially in the STEM field.
- As a mechanic, I learned a lot too.
So when I into engineering,
I was able to view things
through a different lens.
I knew how a machine worked.
I knew how to program.
- To have these engineers come in and say,
"This is what we do on a daily basis.
"These are the skills I
wish I had developed more
"when I was your age."
has a really meaningful impact.
Can we give a huge round of
applause to all of our experts
and guests for coming in today?
(students applaud)